all right tonight we start with what is
shaping up to be a horrible bad five
days for Robert Muller in the Office of
Special Counsel this out-of-control
witch-hunt just suffered two massive
major blows now on Friday and what was
the single biggest beatdown I have ever
seen in my life
a federal judge utterly rebuked a
special counsel and his investigation
slamming its political motivations and
calling out the scope for being way out
of bounds and way beyond their mandate
now the judges name is TS Ellis the
third he told a top molar prosecutor
listeners watch you don't really care
about Mr Man afford spank fraud all the
government does what you really care
about is what information Mr Man afford
can give you that would reflect on mr.
Trump or lead to his prosecution or his
impeachment or whatever that's what
you're really interested in Wow and then
Ellis continued none of that information
has anything to do with links or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the campaign at Donald Trump so I
don't see what relation this indictment
has with anything the special prosecutor
is authorized to investigate because
this goes back to 2005 the judge also
quoted a quote it looks to me instead
that what is happening is that this
investigation was underway
it had something the special prosecutor
took it got indictments and then in a
time-honored practice which I'm fully
familiar with it exists largely in the
drug area if you get somebody in a
conspiracy and get something against
them well then you can tighten the
screws and they will begin to probably
provide information in what you're
really interested in now Ellis finished
his epic beatdown by saying well what we
don't want in this country is we don't
want anyone with unfettered power
now this dressing-down wasn't the only
legal setback for Team Muller on
Saturday yet another federal judge
denied the special counsels request for
delay in its case against Russian
election troll forms and meanwhile a
series of
polls are showing that Muller's
witch-hunt is becoming more and more
unpopular with you the American people
all while President Trump's poll numbers
continue to climb to his highest levels
ever late Friday we also learned a
former member of Muller's team of
investigators there she is
FBI lovebird Lisa Paige she has resigned
in disgrace months after her viciously
anti-trump text revealed the extreme
bias at some of the highest levels of
the FBI and Paige wasn't alone in
resigning another prominent deep State
FBI official longtime Comey ally James a
baker he also resigned late on Friday so
as the deep State now starting to crack
look we're learning even more positive
news about the Inspector General Michael
Horowitz review of Hillary Clinton's
email case his testimony before Congress
has now been postponed but for an
interesting reason after reports show
there's finding he's finding new leads
in this ongoing investigation we're
gonna have all of this and break it all
down tonight with Sarah Carter gregg
jarrett attorney David shown in just a
minute but first other news Iran that
deal weighs in the balance tonight
remember three years ago the Obama
administration signed off on what they
promised would make the world a better
safer place in reality the Iranian
nuclear deal sent boatloads of cash a
hundred and fifty billion dollars worth
to a regime actively plotting to destroy
the United States and our best ally
Israel all while funding terrorism and
proxy wars all around the world death to
America death to Israel now all told we
sent 1.7 billion dollars in your cash to
Iran then unfroze about a hundred and
fifty billion dollars in assets and
loosened a series of sanctions what in
America get in return Oh a promise from
the Muellers chanting death to America
that the rogue Islamic theocracy would
temporarily halt its nuclear weapons
program and of course we knew the
mullahs of Iran were liars and last week
they were proven liars by the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
when he unveiled Iran's secret plans to
further their nuclear ambition
including a project aimed at creating
five warheads each containing a ten
kiloton yield given these damning recent
developments president Trump has now set
to decide the fate of this agreement
tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. Eastern 11:00
Pacific let us be clear the mullahs of
Iran are not good people they've killed
Americans in Iraq they fought proxy wars
they want death to Israel and death to
America you cannot trust people like
this this Agreement does not
sufficiently check their nuclear weapons
programs but none of that seems to
matter to former Secretary of State John
Kerry because this deal was the shining
jewel of his time in the Obama State
Department and he is reportedly pulling
out all the stops to save this horrific
deal which puts the world in danger
including meeting with iran's Foreign
Minister really and other foreign
officials from Germany and France and
the EU who are involved in the agreement
this kind of shadow diplomacy it
undermines the United States on the
world stage it undermines our commander
in chief and it needs to stop now the
president tweeted this quote the u.s.
does not need John Kerry's possibly
illegal shadow diplomacy on the very
badly negotiated or ran deal he was the
one that created this mess in the first
place
Kerry spokesman responded in part quote
secretary Kerry stays in touch with his
former counterparts around the world
just like every previous Secretary of
State of course but this reveals yet
what another standard in our two-tier
justice system let me remind you
remember the former acting Attorney
General Sally Yates she told Congress
that General Michael Flynn was being
investigated in part over Logan Act
violations after he spoke with a Russian
ambassador his soon-to-be counterpart
during president's rums transition I
repeat
during the transition Flynn was
preparing to take over as national
security adviser but there's no Logan
Act violation for John Kerry
okay where are the agents and the FBI
and the DOJ breaking down John Kerry's
door another blatant
example of a two-tier justice system
sadly in this country today you know we
will have full analysis of this
incredibly flawed arand deal and John
Kerry's unauthorized actions will ask
the question tonight it did John Kerry
violate the law right but first the
obstruction and stonewalling from our
Department of Justice has now reached a
fever pitch thousands upon thousands of
documents that have been requested and
subpoenaed by the House Judiciary
Committee by the House Oversight
Committee by the house Intel committee
are still being slow-walked and withheld
or massively redacted in what is a clear
effort to impair the constitutional
right and duty of Congress to check the
DOJ and the executive branch
now the Intel committee chairman Devon
knew Nestle will join us in a second he
is now actively encouraging fellow
lawmakers to hold the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions in contempt of Congress
earlier today sessions responded let's
take a look the Department of Justice
has written him a letter and responded
as appropriate to him the request he's
made is one that the intelligence
community's and Department of Justice
feels is is not granted we've explained
that we'd like we'd be willing to talk
to him about it before are the details
of which I couldn't undiscussed mr.
Attorney General I say this with all
respect where is your urgency you need
to do your job this has gone on way too
long these are legitimate important
requests you are not impervious nor the
DOJ impervious to the rule of law and
our federal system of co-equal branches
of power and checks and balances this is
within their congressional authority
constitutional authority and the DOJ is
clearly stonewalling to prevent further
embarrassment given their pathetic track
record and Hillary Clinton's email case
the rampant potential we know FISA
abuses the ongoing witch-hunt in to
trump Russia collusion which never
happened now if the Attorney General
does not take significant measures to
find urgency
and speed up the delivery of these
requested for months and even years of
unredacted documents than it is time for
sessions Rosenstein and anyone else who
is obstructing Congress's investigation
to be held in contempt and face the
serious legal consequences associated
with it in other words mr. Attorney
General mr. Deputy Attorney General it's
time to decide are you part of the swamp
are you part of the deep state are you
going to fix our justice system and let
Congress do their job this country has a
constitution again separation of powers
co-equal branches of government Congress
has a constitutional role in oversight
stop obstructing and slow-walking them
now let's turn to what might be the most
insane display of left-wing lunacy at a
very long time now President Trump has
picked Jena Haspel to lead the CIA now
over the weekend she actually offered to
withdraw her name from consideration a
bad idea she has faced a firestorm of
criticism only from Democrats in the
mainstream media because they're corrupt
but get this she's being criticized for
being too tough on terrorists ooh I
actually like people that are tough on
terrorists take a look in 2002 she ran a
secret CIA prison for suspected
terrorists in Thailand that used harsh
interrogation tactics including
waterboarding sleep deprivation even
squeezing detainees into coffins you
have questions from the left and the
right on her role in the enhanced
interrogation techniques her role in
potentially destroying the videotapes of
the torture and she's gonna have a tough
hearing on Wednesday at this moment
Donald Trump is effectively asking the
US Senate to promote torture because
Trump is asking the Senate to promote a
US official involved in torture to run
the CIA nominating Gina Haspel Mike
Pompeo is deputy for the job
excuse me harsh you know what Gitmo you
the taxpayers paid for a soccer field
for those in ba
in engaging and killing Americans and we
took care of every dietary concern and
we treated there were only three people
that were waterboarded a president Trump
rightly is not backing down to this
ridiculous criticism he reportedly has
pushed Haspel to stay the course I say
the same thing tonight
hospitals confirmation hearing will take
place this week and rightfully so
I met Gina Haspel once she is a patriot
she loves her country she has worked
hard to protect the American people she
more than deserves this job and I'll
take it a step further we should all
thank God for the people like Gina
Haspel and the important work they did
after 9/11 to keep this country safe and
save American lives only three people
have a waterboarded one of them
Oh Khalid Sheikh Mohammed another former
high-ranking CIA official member Jose
Rodriguez on this very show said no
waterboarding we wouldn't have found
Osama bin Laden's courier and we
wouldn't have gotten bin Laden Thank You
Gina hospital for being a hero and
finally tonight some more good news from
the Trump administration this time from
the first lady amazing day today earlier
Melania Trump unveiled her brand new
initiative it's called be best now the
program focuses on America's children
the hard issues that they face on a
daily basis now the three pillars of the
plan include physical mental well
building being social media use and
ramifications for opioid abuse here's
what the first lady had to say earlier
today I feel strongly that as adults we
can and should be best at educating our
children about the importance of a
healthy and balanced life so today I'm
very excited to announce be best an
awareness campaign dedicated to the most
valuable and fragile among us our
children it's amazing Melania Trump she
speaks five languages English is our
fifth language an amazing initiative and
she deserves a lot of credit now we'll
bring you updates of the program over
the next several months because right
here on Hannity we actually show the
full picture of the Trump administration
like all the success that the media will
never tell you about